we have a clip here from huge in France
anything we need to know for this clip I
have to say before we unveil it I want
to I want to see the clip here in
America people say a lot of [ __ ] Oh
before the clip that doesn't really and
they gets them all wowed about the clip
what you did I loved I thought that was
fantastic and much more on trying to be
honest yes and I want to be surprised
I have no idea what you're doing yeah I
like that okay I just want to say hi to
my two amazing directors Jared Paul and
Andy mogul they're watching us and we
wrote and created the show and I'm so
happy and thankful to have them and here
is a clip of the show wait Conan tell me
what what normally what do they say oh
man - tell me please this I'm doing this
show meaning this is training as a you
know Co we're excited about everything
even why no even when we're not really
excited about I know right Andy you've
watched this per year yeah yeah like oh
man I've been doing a lot of work this
finally is the work that I really
believe in yeah then they come back a
year later they go like oh that movie
was [ __ ] and then but this movie's the
one I believe it usually sometimes
sometimes they do it with in the
interview they sell the movie sell the
movie and then in the end as they're
leaving I go how is the movie they'll go
uh one of the best parts of my job
alright we're in America now I got
trained yeah okay ask me the question so
we have this this special this show huge
in France we have you have anything you
want to say about it
I mean Conan you know it's uh it happens
maybe once in a lifetime to get this
kind of pop opportunity as an actor and
a writer yeah this show it's not only a
show it's um I think this is I mean I've
never I think those guys directors
writers are just amazing and I've um um
you know what I'm honored I'm thankful
and I'm so happy and blessed
that I got to get this project with
Netflix god bless them god bless I mean
Adam I don't need to promote the show
it's all about what I felt it's a love
it's the feeling yeah it's it's it's
friendship be foolish I don't care about
don't show the clip what I want you to
know you went too far you've got to show
the clip Oh in America you have to show
the clip oh yeah
show the clip show - Cley what is he
he's GAD yeah they call him the Seinfeld
of France
aha yeah who does Oh everyone does here
in France they're depressed the fans
they always I don't understand no it's
good it's good it's just it's they see
they see me as you but you if you're me
Who am I why don't you you're still you
but you're also me of France but we're
in France so I don't know so it's me and
then me on the show no it's me and then
you but you I'm still me and you still
you it's right if I wasn't here you
would be me well to them yeah what does
this I can find out yeah can you change
that
what are you could you could you be
somebody else of France
huge in France huge in France will be
available to stream on Netflix April
12th
very happy for you
[Applause]